أسلحة ضخمة ومرعبة
روسيا تعد العدة
، روسيا تصنع أعتى الأسلحة
التطوير لا يتوقف على مدى عشرات العقود
لكن لماذا تصنع روسيا كل هذا؟
أهو لإخافة الغرب وأمريكا أم للتصدي لهم؟
، تستمر أمريكا مع تحالفها الغربي
بسرد التصريحات والتهديدات،
بينما تمضي روسيا قدما بأسلحتها المرعبة،
وعلى الرغم أن أمريكا تمتلك
أقوى الأسلحة في العالم
لكن الخوف من استعادة الدب الروسي
للأمجاد السوفيتية يدب الرعب في قلوبهم،
وكيف سيكون الوضع في أوكرانيا
بعد رؤية هذه الأسلحة المدمرة؟
وما هي الأسلحة الروسية المدمرة
التي يخشى الغرب أن تستخدمها روسيا؟
وما هي الأسلحة التي ترى روسيا
أنها علاج لمشاكلها مع الغرب؟
بينما جعلت روسيا جيشها على أهبة الاستعداد
لاجتياح أوكرانيا، يبدو أن الغرب وأمريكا
سيقفون في وجه هذا الخيار مجددا،
وهو ما يهدد باندلاع حرب عالمية ثالثة،
وأي مصير ينتظر العالم
إن قامت هذه الحرب!!
فهل يعي الروس والأمريكان ذلك؟
خلال الفترة الماضية وصلت قوات روسيا
إلى أراضي بيلاروسيا، لكن عدد هذه القوات
لم يكن متوقعا،
وهم يجرون مناورات غير عادية
على الحدود مع أوكرانيا،
فمن يستطيع أن يمنع الكارثة؟
فيما لو قررت روسيا غزو أوكرانيا؟
وفيما لو عدنا للسلاح الروسي فما الذي يجعله مخيفا
إلى هذه الدرجة؟
وبالأحرى ما هي هذه الأسلحة التي تثير الرعب لدى الغرب؟
بالتوازي مع أمريكا تمتلك روسيا أقوى السلاح في العالم،
لذلك لا يجب التغافل عن هذه الحقيقة،
فأمريكا تمتلك أقوى الأسلحة في العالم ومستمرة بتطويره،
وهي تحظى بدعم دولي كبير،
لكن هنا سنعرض لكم أخطر الأسلحة الروسية،،،
قامت الحرب العالمية الأولى بأسلحة قديمة
فكانت أضرارها مقتصرة على البشر
أما اليوم فإن الأسلحة النووية
ستدمر الحجر والشجر والبشر،
فهي لا تبقي ولا تذر،،
...
ليس هذا فحسب، فروسيا تعمل على تدريب الروبوتات العسكرية
وتطويرها، ما سبب ضجة في وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي،
بل أن ذلك نشر الرعب في العالم بأسره،
فجنود الروبوتات هذه يتم تدريبها على سرعة القنص
والتفريق بين المواطن والرجل المسلح،
والاشتباكات وفضها،
قوة رهيبة تمتلكها روسيا بامتلاكها لهذه الروبوتات!!!،
فهؤلاء الجنود الآليون على عكس البشر في المعارك
فهم لا يحتاجون للأكل أو الشرب ويمكن أن يتحركوا
بالطاقة الشمسية، ولا ينامون ولا يتعبون،
بل ولا يتوقفون قبل الوصول لهدفهم،
ما هذا الرعب الذي ينشره الروس!!،،،
فهل يكتفي الروس بهذا؟
لا وإليكم بقية الأسلحة المدمرة...
(سلاح الشمس الحارقة)
أحد أعظم الأسلحة في العالم،
هو سلاح روسي يحول الهواء إلى لهب،
هل تصدق ذلك؟!!
هو السلاح الذي يحرق الأخضر واليابس،
سلاح فتاك يدمر الأهداف بسهولة بالغة،
يكفي فقط أن يصل إليها،
ما يسهل المهمة للجنود من خلفه،
وهو تطوير لسياسة روسية قديمة كانت تدعى
(الأرض المحروقة)،
هو السلاح الروسي الجديد الذي يبيد العدو أينما كان،
فلن تجدي أمامه نفعا حتى القلاع المحصنة،
إنه قاذفة الصواريخ الحرارية،
أو ما يسمى بسلاح الشمس الحارقة
(TOS-1A Solntsepek)،
قاذفات اللهب الثقيلة  هذه،
تستخدم ذخائر متفجرة تعمل بالوقود الجوي
تدمر دفاعات العدو بضربة واحدة،
لتدخل الدبابات والجنود الحاملون للبنادق الآلية  بعدها
في الاشتباك، وبشكل أساسي، لن يكون هناك من يقاومهم،
ما يجعل الحرب مجرد نزهة للجنود،،
فأنظمة Solntsepek
تخلق دماراً كاملاً على مساحة كبيرة"
، وهي مناسبة لاختراق المناطق المحصنة بشدة،
يا لهذا السلاح العظيم!!!!
إنه سلاح مجهز لاجتياح المدن،
سلاح يحاول الأمريكان حظره دوليا،
بحجة أنه عشوائي ويؤثر على المدنيين
بالدرجة الأولى، فهل هذا صحيح؟
أم أن أمريكا تخاف أن تستخدمه روسيا ضدها
لو اندلعت الحرب؟
الى جانب قاذفات اللهب،
يأتي سلاح (غواصة "وسيدوون")
المسيرة النووية التي بمقدورها مهاجمة
الساحل الأمريكي في أي موقع.
ومن الصعب اكتشافها لأنها تسير تحت الماء
على عمق كبير بسرعة هائلة.
وتتميز بالتخفي عن الرادارات المائية.
وستحمل الطوربيد النووي المسيّر
غواصة نووية أخرى كبيرة الحجم
قد خضعت لاختبارات.
يبدو أن الروس قد بثوا الرعب في نفوس أعدائهم!!
ما هذه الأسلحة المدمرة التي يمتلكونها!!،،،
لو اندلعت الحرب أيضا فنهاك سلاح يخيف الغرب
بقدر الأسلحة السابقة، وهو منظومة
"إس – 400" للدفاع الجوي
والتي تخصص لاعتراض مختلف الأهداف الجوية
بدءا من الدرونات وانتهاءان بالصواريخ الباليستية.
وقد بيعت المنظومة لكل من الهند وتركيا والصين.
وهذه الدول الأخيرة يبدو أنها من أقوى الحلفاء
إلى جانب الروس فالتنين الصيني
مع الدب الروسي يشكلان تحالفا يخيف حلف الناتو،،،
لم ننتهي بعد فما أكثر أنواع الأسلحة لدى الروس،،
مروحية " مي – 28 إن إم"  وتدعى ب(صياد الليل).
وفيها العديد من الأسلحة الخطيرة،
وبينها مدفع عيار 30 ملم،
وصواريخ "أتاكا" المضادة للدبابات،
والصواريخ غير الموجهة، ومدافع إضافية،
أما الرادار المنصوب تحت مروحتها الأمامية
فيضمن الرصد الدائري.
وقد تم تجربة المروحية في منطقة الشرق الأوسط.
آخر الأسلحة في هذا الفيديو وهو ليس الأخير لروسيا،
التي تمتلك أنواعا كثيرة من الأسلحة يصعب سردها في فيديو واحد..
صاروخ "يارس"، وتنتج روسيا نموذجين منه:
أحدهما ينصب على منصة ثابتة وثانيهما على منصة متحركة.
وتتطلب عملية إعداد الصاروخ للإطلاق 8 دقائق فقط.
وبمقدور صاروخ "يارس أن ينقل 6 رؤوس
إلى مسافة تزيد عن 10 آلاف كيلومتر.
ويمكن تزويده كذلك برأس "أفانغارد"
فرط الصوتية المزودة بمحرك نووي.
السلاح الروسي بإمكانه أن يدمر البشر والحجر والشجر،
لكن الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية لا تقل شأنا عن روسيا
في مجال الأسلحة، وهنا لسنا نتحدث عن مقارنة
بين الطرفين، لكن سيكون لنا فيديو آخر
يتحدث عن السلاح الأمريكي،،،
وتبقى روسيا هي الكفة الأخرى في ميزان القوى
الذي يحمل في كفته الأخرى الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية،
فمن سينتصر لو اندلعت حرب بين الطرفين؟ ...